all right let's start with what the
media will not tell you tonight some of
the biggest news in today's indictment
is what is not included it does not say
that Donald Trump colluded with the
Russians it does not say that anybody on
the Trump campaign colluded with the
Russians it does not say that President
Trump obstructed justice it does not say
that Donald Trump jr. attempted to
collude with the Russians now the same
goes for Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn and the Attorney General jeff
Sessions the biggest examples of Russian
collusion for 2016 that we know about
that we have real concrete evidence of
is one Hillary Clinton her bought and
paid for dossier the one that used
Russian government sources to peddle
Russian propaganda lies to influence the
American people in this past election in
2016 and the other example of Russia
collusion number two is that we know to
be true deals with uranium one and
Vladimir Putin and people he had on the
ground in America or involved in bribery
and money laundering and kickback and
racketeering schemes it all took place
in this country we know all about that
we'll have more later on this tonight
but first here are the key points from
this indictment 13 Russian nationals
three Russian companies launched the
campaign of information warfare it
started back in 2014 and eventually
culminated in interfering with the 2016
election the goal was simple to sow
political discord in the United States
of America yeah no kidding and we have
been telling you all about uranium one
all about the dossier filled with
Russian lies now this is critical after
the election these same Russian trolls
that attempted to undermine then
president-elect Donald Trump well they
went out there president Trump finally
is reacting to this today because they
were undermining the president after the
election Russia started their anti US
campaign in 2014
long before he announced that he would
run for president he said I and then the
results of the election were not
impacted the Trump campaign did nothing
wrong no collusion now the White House
they also put out a statement tonight
quoting the president they said quote it
is more important than ever before to
come together as Americans
we cannot allow those seeking to sow
confusion discord rancor to be
successful it's time we stop the
outlandish partisan attacks the wild
false allegations the far-fetched
theories which only serve to further the
agendas of bad actors like Russia and do
nothing to protect the principles of our
institutions we must unite as Americans
to protect the integrity of our
democracy our elections
now what this indictment shows is
nothing short of a sophisticated effort
by the Russians to gain influence in
America now we have been telling you
this about Vladimir Putin about Russian
operatives about how they've been
involved in sophisticated schemes we
have been going back to as early as 2009
remember he had people operatives on the
ground with the purpose of breaking into
America's uranium market and we also
told you how those Russian operatives
were involved and we knew it because we
had an insider on the ground an FBI
informant that they were involved in
bribery and kickbacks and money
laundering racketeering all in this
scheme yes tied to Hillary Clinton now
that's the deal with a Clinton State
Department and the Obama administration
they ignored this FBI investigation what
this informant was telling them was
going on on the inside and inexplicably
they approved in 2010 giving Vladimir
Putin control of over 20% of America's
uranium market we had the informant
warning us on the inside the entire time
nobody listened and the clueless media
they ignored this Russian interference
now this only matters apparently if the
Russians are involved if you can use it
to bludgeon president Trump politically
sadly Putin and Russia they were
successful in 2010 they got that uranium
now even though we already have a
shortage of uranium in America we have
to import uranium now let's get back to
this indictment it lays out allegations
that begin in 2014 where Russian
nationals they were working together
with a troll farm located and seen st.
Petersburg Russia trying to influence
the election why wouldn't they after
they got uranium now they did this by
quote
as US persons in creating false us
personas operated social media pages and
groups designed to attract US audiences
now these Russian trolls also staged
political rallies while pretending to be
American political activists and paid
Americans in the u.s. to attack certain
candidates this operation at a monthly
budget of over a million dollars it
included Russians that were operating
inside this country just like they were
in 2009 in this case again the Russians
got caught red-handed and as we have
been explaining well there were no
Americans including anybody from the
Trump campaign that were knowingly
involved and these efforts did not
impact the election results now here's
what the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein said earlier today now there
is no allegation in this indictment that
any American was a knowing participant
in this illegal activity there is no
allegation in the indictment that the
charged conduct altered the outcome of
the 2016 election and all you people in
the media that paid no attention to
Putin and his operatives in 2009 and 10
and uranium one pay close attention to
what Rosenstein says here take a listen
the Russians also recruited and paid
real americans to engage in political
activities promote political campaigns
and staged political rallies the
defendants and their co-conspirators
pretended to be grassroots activists
according to the indictment the
Americans did not know that they were
communicating with Russians after the
election the defendants allegedly staged
rallies to support the president-elect
while simultaneously staging rallies to
protest his election for example the
defendants organized one rally to
support the president-elect and another
rally to impose to oppose him both in
New York on the same day both in New
York the same day so the Russians were
actually organizing rallies and engaging
in political activities for both
campaigns and after the election they
were seeking to undermine then
president-elect Donald Trump here's how
the indictment lays it out quote in or
around November 2016 defendants and
their
conspirators organized a rally in New
York through one organization control
groups designed to show your support for
president elect Donald Trump held on or
about November 12 2016 at the exact same
time defendants and their
co-conspirators through another
organization control group they
organized the rally also in New York
called Trump is not my president held on
or about November 12 2016 now similarly
defendants in their co-conspirators
organized a rally entitled Charlotte
against Trump in Charlotte North
Carolina
held on or about November 19 2016 so
this wasn't as one-sided as the media is
trying to make this out to be in fact
this indictment continues to prove that
the media has been wrong and lying to
the American people no evidence for over
a year now pushing their bizarre
conspiracy theories about Trump Russia
collusion that with no evidence is not
existent you may remember a lot of this
a dizzying 24 hours in the Russia
investigation no longer just inching
toward the president this morning it is
more like careening I think this is a
potentially more dangerous situation
than Watergate and we're at a very
dangerous moment and that's because we
are looking at the possibility that the
President of the United States and those
around him during an election campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it hurricane vladimer if you
will the whole Russian thing this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question that what he is doing is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy Tom
Friedman said the election hacking is at
the caliber of a Pearl Harbor or a 9/11
to agree with that I completely agree
with that Donald Trump now sits at the
threshold of impeachment it's been over
a year these types of comments without
any evidence facts obviously don't
matter to the fake news media no
evidence of collusion and this
indictment says that no American
the Trump campaign wittingly tried to
help the Russians now I know a lot of
people are shocked by this indictment
and there was a gigantic collective gasp
from liberals the mainstream media when
this news came out earlier today why is
anybody surprised that's my question
Russia an election interference it goes
back decades and as we have been
reporting an FBI informant that is now
talking to three separate congressional
committees in just the last couple of
weeks well he discovered back in 2009
undercover for six years toll all told
in his life thirty years but he noticed
in 2009 it was an informant with the FBI
about a plan that Vladimir Putin had to
corner America's uranium market this all
started in 2009 then he discovered there
was bribery kickbacks money laundering
racketeering and other types of
extortion going on the FBI then run by
Robert Muller
they were being informed every step of
the way and they did nothing robert
muller has some questions to answer and
this informant is also saying Russian
paid millions to a lobbying firm all in
an attempt to influence then Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton that company
APCO Worldwide they deny the allegations
now this putin led operation back in
2009 nobody in the media is telling you
started over years before a year and a
half before the sofia sport that's nine
obama federal agencies including Hillary
at Secretary of State Eric Holder at
justice approved the sale of uranium one
and keep players involved in that
decision they should have known all of
this was going on but they approved it
anyway and the real question is knowing
all of this knowing Putin's efforts in
no.9 and knowing we didn't have enough
uranium in America why would Sofia sand
all these agencies and the Obama
administration why did they allow Russia
a hostile foreign entity to take control
of 20% of our uranium the foundational
material to make nuclear weapons and
we're supposed to be surprised at
today's indictments now here's the other
aspect of all of this the left the
corrupt media will never tell you about
the Russian influence campaign alright
this that they told you about today goes
back to 2014 where how was the Obama
administration
what did they do then to stop this now
remember NBC News reported after the
election the Obama administration didn't
do more to stop Russia because they
thought Hillary was going to win
that's NBC so in other words it sounds
like the Obama administration they were
complicit in this they dropped the ball
and they were definitely in this case
more warning signs you can shake a stick
at in April 2016
the House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez he warned America's
inability to predict Vladimir Putin's
plans would be quote the biggest
intelligence failure that we have had
since 9/11 how right sadly he was now
Barack Obama needs to tell you the
American people what he knew and when he
knew it maybe Obama didn't take the
Russian threat seriously
remember back during the 2012 election
during a debate he was mocking Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney was warning about the
Russian threat take a look Governor
Romney I'm glad that you recognized that
al Qaeda is a threat because a few
months ago when you were asked what's
the biggest geopolitical threat facing
America you said Russia not al-qaeda you
said Russia and the 1980s are now
calling to ask for their foreign policy
back because you know the Cold War has
been over for 20 years yeah a year later
Putin has people bribing extorting money
laundering all in America to get
involved in our uranium markets given
what we know now
President Obama hit the top members of
his administration they owe you an
explanation
Hillary owes you an explanation because
what this did is a dereliction of duty
they failed to stop a major national
security threat we did reach out to
Obama's office for comments shockingly
we haven't heard back and another
example of Russian collusion of course
is the Clinton bought and paid for
dossier filled with Russian and Russian
government lies and propaganda now
Hillary Clinton at the DNC they shelled
out what over 12 million dollars to fund
this salacious and of course unverified
dossier that was later used as the bulk
of information to get a FISA warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign the same
dossier the Republican memos found that
the FBI used to lie in that FISA Court
to get that warrant
to spy on a member of the Trump campaign
the FBI fusion GPS
nobody verified what was in the dossier
to this day we haven't proven a thing in
that dossier and we now know that the
bulk of that a FISA application was made
up of a political hit piece document put
together by a former British spy
Christopher Steele using Russian
government sources oh and some of
Hillary's best friend is sources now
also breaking this hour a lot of
developments tonight as it relates to
the case of Bruce and Nellie or now we
first reported on this husband-and-wife
duo after it was discovered that Bruce
or remember the high-ranking Justice
Department official remember he passed
on the anti-trump steel dossier he gave
it to the FBI it was his wife Nellie
working for fusion GPS on the dossier
and according to a report in the Daily
Caller Bruce or he attempted to hide now
his wife's involvement with fusion gps
by not disclosing on required legal
ethic forms that Nellie or was being
paid by fusion GPS instead or listed his
wife as a cyber security analyst and did
not disclose fusion GPS in any way but
that's not all according to the report
briefs Bruce or quote did not obtain a
conflict of interest waiver from his
superiors at the Justice Department
so was Bruce or intentionally covering
up his wife's involvement with fusion
GPS and that Russian dossier and given
that intentionally falsifying government
ethics documents can result in jail time
is Muller's investigation are they going
to charge Bruce or don't hold your
breath
now also tonight new information about
James commis memos Byron York Washington
Examiner points out a very interesting
article with the headline why are the
Comey memos secret now Byron York
supporting that in July of 2017 the FBI
did allow lawmakers to see the memo
about commis version of conversations
that he had with President Trump later
leaked to the professor that leaked to
the FBI that led to robert muller but
anyway the FBI made sure the information
in these memos was severely restricted
why would that be now Comey testified
under oath that he gave the memos to
that friend they leaked it to the New
York Times they hunt in the hopes that
Robert
would be appointed a special counsel it
happened now you would think that if
those memos were so explosive and so
damning and so damaging and proved
obstruction of justice which we keep
hearing about like Comey and the media
and the Democrats are all claiming that
why don't we release the memos but
they're keeping them secret for a reason
take a look at how congressman trey
Gowdy South Carolina described the memos
back in December the obstruction of
justice remember that started being
discussed when Comey had these memos
that he said he made I've read the memos
I've read every one at commis memos they
would be defense Exhibit A in an
obstruction of justice case not
prosecution exhibit defense Exhibit A
if Comey felt obstructed he did a
masterful job of keeping it out of any
of his memos defense Exhibit A so the
entire so-called scandal with the memo
created by Comey perpetrated by
Democrats and the left-wing media
complicit with the Democrats it's
absolutely a farce it's a mere political
tactic it's been used to damage
president Trump and undermine his
presidency
now all the koma koma memos should be
released what are they hiding
now also tonight while today's
indictments show that Muller is
conducting serious work in the ongoing
Russia investigation which by the way
nobody should be surprised about there
are still deeply concerning issues
surrounding the team of liberal anti
Trump partisan investigators that Muller
tapped to lead his probe now this
includes Mulder's top prosecutor Andrew
Weissman or the New York Times calls him
molars pitbull now for months we've been
reporting on Weissman's generous
donations to Democratic political
campaigns including thousands to
President Obama The Wall Street Journal
had revealed that Weissman actually
attended the 2016 election a victory
party for Hillary Clinton and you can't
forget that Weissman actually prays then
acting Attorney General Sally Yates for
defying president Trump's travel ban
after she was fired now aside from
Weissman's clear political bias the
longtime prosecutor has also been
accused of employing aggressive sketchy
prosecutorial tactics which led to the
imprisonment of four innocent merrill
lynch executives that case was
ultimately overturned by the Fifth
Circuit Court
peels and Weissman's aggressive
prosecution's also led to the downfall
of the accounting giant Arthur Andersen
tens of thousands of people lost their
jobs and by the way the Supreme Court
they overturned him again
nine zero in that case we also have a
brand new damning report tonight Sarah
Carter will join us in a minute
detailing even more misconduct including
a 1997 case about Andrew Weissman that
was he was officially reprimanded by the
judge for withholding evidence when he
failed to disclose that a witness on
behalf of the prosecution was also
working for years as an FBI informant
this is in a organized crime case in a
memorandum the judge reportedly
described Weissman's conduct as quote
myopic withholding of information
reprehensible and subject perhaps to
appropriate disciplinary measures oh
that's the guy Muller hired
ultimately no such measures were taken
Weissman's name was retroactively ly
wiped from the complaint and after a
Weitzman Ally fought to remove his name
and more recently Weissman was reported
to the Department of Justice Inspector
General and the Senate Judiciary
Committee for quote corrupt corrupt
legal practices in fact civil rights
attorney David Schon
he called for Weissman to be
investigated for this alleged past
misconduct we did reach out to the
special counsels office for comments on
Sarah's reporting shockingly
they don't answer our calls the sum of
all of this is this the big news today
zero evidence again a year plus no
evidence that Trump his campaign
colluded in any way shape matter or form
we have been telling you this for over
here show us the evidence we want to see
it now it's time for the Democrats and
the media to finally start telling the
truth to you the American people about
the situation and that means to tell you
about real collusion as it relates to
uranium 1 in 2009 as it relates to why
would you ever allow Putin and his
operatives to get away with that and
number two as it relates to the bought
and paid for phony dossier that was all
designed to manipulate the American
people